[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 la edición número
75 del festival de canal la cita
indiscutible del cine mundial se
clausuró hace unos días bajo el sol del
sur de francia se proyectaron cerca de
100 películas de todo el mundo y tras 10
días de competición y 21 películas
examinadas desde todos los ángulos
el jurado coronó al cineasta sueco ruben
ostlund ya que su película traen gol o
salnés triángulo de tristeza ganó el
trofeo más prestigioso la palma de oro a
mejor película traigo los arneses es una
comida deliberadamente escandalosa que
cuenta la historia de un grupo de ultra
ricos egoístas y engreídos durante en
cruceros sí mismo ironía y caricatura
componen la receta de esta sátira ácida
sobre la lucha de clases así rubén os
room entró en el exclusivo club de los
dobles ganadores del prestigioso
galardón ya que hace cinco años ganó su
primera palma de oro por su square una
crítica del mundo arte contemporáneo el
director sueco nos explicó por qué le
interesa filmar sus personajes en
situaciones de crisis
me gusta la idea de que durante una
crisis intentamos dar la apariencia de
que todo va bien que intentamos
comportarnos como deberíamos pero que no
siempre lo conseguimos las crisis
también revelan la verdadera
personalidad de las personas su
incivismo su reacción primaria al estrés
es un gran alivio filmar estas
situaciones porque me dijo a mí mismo
que solo soy un ser humano que a veces
actuaría como la gente de mis películas
para el gran premio el segundo galardón
más prestigioso del festival el jurado
decidió no decidir entre dos películas
que finalmente empataron a stars nun y
close estas son las obras de una
veterana del cine de la francesa claire
denis y el director más joven de la
competición el belga lukas doms con
estar desnudo que la dueña se traslada a
una nicaragua al borde de la guerra
civil para retratar la vacilante pasión
de dos desconocidos con el telón de
fondo del espionaje industrial con
centro
es kirchner
[Música]
un thriller destrozado por la crítica al
revés de closed donde lucas de un film a
la amistad funcional de dos chicos antes
de que todo se rompa trágicamente por la
mirada normativa de sus compañeros de
clase tras la revelación de guión
premiada con la cámara de oro en 2018 el
director belga de 31 años continúa su
examen de la construcción social del
género
corea del sur destacó este año con dos
importantes premios el genial actor
supongo que se dio a conocer en
parásitos en 2019 fue recompensado por
su papel de traficante de bebés en
broker la última película del director
japonés hirokazu kore eda rodada en
corea del sur y su compatriota el
cineasta park songbook se alzó con el
premio al mejor director por decidió en
to live decisión de irse una historia de
detectives entre misterio y sensualidad
y por el premio a mejor actriz del
jurado reconoció la valiente carrera de
la iraní shahram y evra y su papel de
periodista que investiga los asesinatos
de prostitutas cometidos en nombre de
dios en el thriller holy spider un
premio que irán a calificó de
tendencioso y político pero que tiene
sabor a victoria para dar a mi ere brain
in que tuvo que exiliarse en francia en
2008 tras un escándalo sexual la
escuchamos esponjoso firma con esta
película tuvimos la oportunidad de
mostrar lo que queríamos porque la
hicimos fuera de irán sin censura
y esta vez no había mujeres en casa con
velo en la cama con velo con poca monta
de esto es cuando les podemos mostrar lo
que quisiéramos y como resultado
mostramos realmente los rostros de
mujeres diversas que nos representan el
cine iraní y esa fue la ventaja no haya
ganado esas alabanzas y con esta edición
75 el festival de cannes logró encontrar
su equilibrio una vez más entre
películas para un público de cinéfilos y
estrenos de filmes más accesibles con
temas más ligeros este año hay dos obras
fuera de la competición que hicieron
soñar a los espectadores de cana por el
gran espectáculo que ofrecen a la
divertida top rick y la deslumbrante
elvis esta isla explora el ascenso y la
caída de la estrella de rock and roll
elvis presley y llevada por la
extravagante dirección artística del
australiano baz luhrmann a un torbellino
visual que consigue contar la historia
tanto del hombre como de los estados
unidos de los años 50 60 y 70
ninguno
y después de 30 años sin pisar la
alfombra roja del festival de cannes el
actor tom cruise volvió para presentar
tu avión may freak dirigido por joseph
kosinski la secuela de la película de
culto de
1986 además con el motivo de la subida
de la escalera del equipo de la película
los aviones de la patrulla del homes
iluminaron el cielo de caná un
espectáculo a la escala del éxito de
tokio en male break en los cines que
domina la taquilla mundial y que se
convirtió en el mejor estreno en la
carrera de tempus nos despedimos
entonces con el traidor gracias por su
confianza y cuídense
yo soy yo
[Música]
de dónde está
pero la magia
mi familia
[Música]